you have you seen bay aka or formerly
known as most def on the project kind of
crazy that's crazy you hear that verse i
have not i have not yet
but let me tell you something
i just had a um
con mate me and conway were running
around in denver last week and we're
listening to respiration by black star
and we're going back and forth about
childhood quality versus most
and i was like
i love tyler that's my guy but i'm like
i don't even think it's discussion i
think most definitely
if most def like applied himself in
hip-hop he'd be like
[ __ ] man you got to think like black we
got black on both sides and black star
and then what was the name of the album
that came out like a few years later
where he had the [ __ ] over his face i
had sunshine on there but i feel like he
always was one foot in one foot out with
the rap [ __ ] for real like imagine if he
really was like dug in it would have
been crazy yeah
have been cool i heard chappelle say
like even the way he moved is just like
super brilliant too i think because i
heard chappelle say something like
artists
don't you shouldn't want to be a
commodity you know what i'm saying
you get you know what i'm saying
yeah
i feel like that's like kind of a
powerful ass statement to accept you
know i'm saying commodities are like
water
like right all the [ __ ] that you need
but it's just like no you don't want to
be seen as that you want to be seen as
like 101 or you want to be seen as a
fingerprint snowflake or some [ __ ]
no it's kind of deep to me so i think
you're doing a pretty good job of that
yeah yeah for sure yeah
[Music]
my favorite artists
are consistent but it's more so in their
product
you know what i'm saying they're not
always in your face but when they come
they come with that it matters that's
what that's that's what i love about it
yeah i love artists that drop a lot of
consistency as well like a lot of trap
artists like stay on it like that's
their bag and that shit's beautiful i
love it